postal worker admits fabricating
allegations of ballot tampering
officials say and they have this really
like generic photo of a fake Ballot Box
I guess a Pennsylvania postal worker
whose claims have been cited by top
Republican Republicans as potential
evidence of widespread voting
irregularities admitted to U.S Postal
Service investigators that he fabricated
the allegations according to three
officials briefed on the investigation
and a statement from a house
Congressional committee Richard Hopkins
claims that a postmaster in Erie PA
instructed postal workers to back date
ballots mailed after election day was
cited by Senator Lindsey Graham in a
letter to the justice department calling
for a federal investigation Attorney
General William P Barr subsequently
authorized Federal prosecutors to open
probes into credible allegations of
voting regularities and fraud a reversal
of long-standing justice department
policy but on Monday Hopkins 32 told
investigators from the United from the
U.S Postal Service Officer office of
Inspector General that the allegations
were not true and he signed an affidavit
recanting his claims according to
officials who spoke on the condition of
anonymity to describe an ongoing
investigation Democrats on the house
oversight committee tweet did it late
Tuesday that quote whistleblower
completely recanted Hopkins did not
respond to messages seeking comment
here's what gets interesting according
to Hopkins he did he tried very much so
to get a comment saying this is not true
and now we have this tweet from James
O'Keefe in fact we have two James
O'Keefe says recording federal agents
coerce USPS whistleblower Hopkins to
water down story
Hopkins doubles down agent Strasser I am
trying to twist you a little bit quote I
am scaring you here we have Senators
involved doj involved reason they called
me is to try to harness
so I can play some of the uh the audio
here and I think it should work the the
Veritas video starts by them you know
explaining Who The Whistleblower is what
he was saying and uh let me just let me
let me just play it's two minutes they
were grilling the hell out of me how are
you feeling right now I'm kind of pissed
I feel like I just got played and I
heard him say
to the supervisor that they messed up
yesterday that they and I was so I was
like oh what do they mess up on and uh
he told the the supervisor that um
they had uh postmarked one of the
pallets for the fourth
instead of the third as they were
supposed to hit uh put them for third
so now it's giving us an explanation
I'll jump I'll jump forward check this
out
and so let me let me make good on that
promise right away okay this storm is
getting crazy right yes it's out of a
lot of people's control and so the
reason they called me in is to try to
harness that storm try to reel it back
in before it gets really crazy do you
understand because we have Senators
involved we have the Department of
Justice involved we have almost lawyers
teams starting a hold of me I I I'm not
well I am I am trying to twist you a
little bit because in that believe it or
not your mind will kick in okay
um we like to control our mind and when
we do that we can convince ourselves of
a memory but when you're under a little
bit of stress which is what I'm doing to
you all purposely
um your mind can be a little bit clearer
and we're going to do a different
exercise too to make your mind a little
bit clearer so but this is all on
purpose Roger I'm not scaring you but I
am scaring you it seems like they were
trying to make me distrust y'all and at
the same time it it kind of affected but
at the same time I was like nah these
guys have had my back since the get-go
so that's why I continued do you think
these federal agents have your back
at this point no do you think these
federal agents are really interested in
investigating fraud
honestly I don't think they are and in
fact you heard weisenberg tell a
supervisor they were backeding the
ballots to make it appear they've been
collected November 3rd you still stand
by that yeah yes
so that's it uh apologies for those who
can't see it our monitor broke
apparently I can't show it but that's
just a bit of the audio they put out so
far I imagine that James he usually does
longer form versions of this on his
website
I guess you can choose to trust uh James
O'Keefe he's got a whistleblower he's
got a signed sworn affidavit we got
video of the guy delivering the mail I
don't know what else we need to go on to
say here's a guy saying they were back
dating ballots but it's very very weird
it's very very Brazen to see The
Washington Post to be like the story's
fakey recanted then this guy to come
back out immediately be like I never
recanted
so we got we got this tweet from house
uh
oversight Democrat saying breaking news
Erie PA USPS whistleblower completely
recanted his allegations of a supervisor
tampering with mail-in ballots after
being questioned by investigators
according to ig here are the facts
Richard Hopkins is a USPS employee in
Erie Pennsylvania so that's not in
dispute he signed a sworn affidavit with
allegations of ballot tampering and
fraud and went public through project
Veritas USPS IG began investigating last
week IG investigators informed committee
staff today that they interviewed
Hopkins on Friday but that Hopkins
recanted his allegations yesterday and
did not explain why he signed a false
affidavit so now not only do we have
this video from James O'Keefe where they
play the audio but James actually put
out a tweet of uh okay I guess I don't
know where it is it's the guy or at
least I thought he had the Tweet maybe
it's on Project Veritas he's actually
sitting with with the guy I guess in a
hotel room and the guy like is looking
at the Washington Post story and says
this is not true I did not recant this
so
I don't know one thing that sticks out
to me when I look at this Washington
Post summary is that of course the
relaying this claim
that Hopkins
recanted his allegations by way of this
laundered anonymity which always should
raise a red flag I don't care what it
pertains to I mean this was done
constantly over the course of Russia
gate where Anonymous U.S officials were
quoted as characterizing certain things
often you didn't even get a direct quote
from them
and so
The Washington Post or any other media
outlet should not be surprised when
people look at a story like this look at
this summation that's totally
non-specific
and view it ascans right so it's
possible that Hopkins as claimed in this
story didn't fact sign an affidavit
recanting his Clans we don't know that
the James will keep stuff you just play
doesn't necessarily dispute that it
could provide countervailing evidence to
maybe say that it was done on a duress
or something
but the problem in terms of any
outstanding apprehension about the
veracity of the story stems from The
Wonton Yusuf anonymity that is so
ubiquitous across the media that it just
inevitably is going to engender
suspicion and rightly so
this is a common
common thing they do with Anonymous
sources how is this okay
we we talked to some Anonymous person
you don't know who it is trust us the
story is not true he didn't give us a
comment well according to them he's like
to veritas this guy's straight up saying
it didn't happen
my question is you know an anonymity can
sometimes be justified like it's a valid
device in journalistic practice but you
have to be transparent about why you're
doing it I mean there's no clear reason
at least that's stated here as to why
this individual apparently associated
with the U.S Postal Service office of
Inspector General ought to have been
granted I know maybe in the first place
like if you have the affidavit
why not provide it when you're saying
because it's an ongoing investigation
what does that mean exactly it's so
vague that right The Washington Post is
asking the reader to just instinctively
trust their veracity and so often
they've proved that they don't deserve
that trust so what are we supposed to
believe right now
well I mean I don't know that let's say
that the
story that's put forward by Hopkins as
relayed by James O'Keefe is entirely
accurate I mean I think I heard there
correct me if I'm wrong but I think
Hopkins was referring to one ballot that
was changed in Erie County now like they
they specific so that one count one
ballot was
receiving the fourth and then was back
dated to the third right or did I hear
that wrong you did you know you heard it
right but the full context is that he
overheard them saying they were back
dating ballots and he was instructed to
bring any ballots from after the
election to them because they were back
dating them
okay so I want to uh keep going so let's
just let's just assume that it's that
all that is true
whether that suggests some kind of
systematic
fraud I think is far from established
particularly in Pennsylvania where it
probably wouldn't have made
a difference in the outcome anyway I
mean when all the votes are counted
um the margin could be as much as a
hundred thousand votes for for Biden so
I think you know it would be expected
and in fact I would be surprised if
there weren't incidences of isolated
fraudulent activity
um but I think feeding a narrative where
all this is supposed to indicate the
that the entire election should be
negated or something I think I mean
we're going to need a whole lot more
evidence than has been provided so far
so I uh so I just wanted to make sure I
double checked from Veritas they say The
Insider said quote we have to separate
up the ballots and give them directly to
the supervisors they're post-marking and
they're at the office and taking them
directly to The Ballot Box he and that
specifically says
uh all these ballots that were coming in
today tomorrow yesterday are all
supposed to be postmarked the Third
so that's the official claim it's
interesting I was watching uh the five
earlier you know on Fox and Greg Gutfeld
was saying I think it was Greg and I
think it was also Jesse kind of both
saying uh Jesse Waters and Greg Gutfeld
that we don't we're not right now at the
point where we bring out big old stacks
of evidence that something happened
we're at the point where we're like we
have some sworn affidavits that should
warrant an inquiry or an investigation
and then you go and find evidence
assuming these accusations are are
correct we've got I think uh I don't
know how many three or four perhaps
maybe maybe it's three poll Watchers who
have signed sworn affidavits saying that
they've seen some kind of fraud I'm not
saying widespread I'm saying we have
three affidavits is it enough to change
an election I honestly well if you think
about a three affidavits in a country of
330 million that has converted on Moss
to mail when voting is really not that
many
yeah I guess so the point being brought
up on the five was
we're talking about a few key swing
districts and we're talking about a very
very narrow race where if you witness
someone doing something improper then
that needs to be investigated and then
we could potentially find more evidence
of of a larger scale impropriety or or
over uh uh fraud I guess I guess the
question I would have is like what does
larger scale impropriety mean if there's
something systematic and fraudulent then
that would have to be coordinated in
some way or would have to I think be
more of a cohesive initiative to change
the outcome of the election than has
been anything close to establish I mean
you can go back years and decades and
find isolated incidences of fraud I mean
there was
um in 1960 JFK it's thought could have
won the election over Richard Nixon
because of straight up election fraud
that happened in in the Deep South so I
think nobody who is aware of History
should discount that out of hand what's
what's the uh what's the vote margin in
PA right know legit question the vote
margin in Pennsylvania is Biden is ahead
by point eight percent
um and that's probably going to continue
to to go up so I mean it's like 45 000
votes or something isn't it right now
it's yeah it's uh 60 70 000 or so yeah
seventy thousand seventy three thousand
and it's probably going to inch up
continuously to forty four hundred
thousand range so I mean like that's not
a margin I mean that's not Florida two
thousand that's not anything right close
to a point where it's even beyond the
threshold where there will be an
automatic recount in Pennsylvania right
so so AP has it around I think I'm
looking at 47 yeah 47 700 or so that
would require every like that would
require numerous post offices being in
uh you're right sorry I misread that
thing but to get that margin because
we're also talking about hundreds of
thousands of votes that came in to get a
margin where it's going to you know be
able to actually overturn Pennsylvania
that's
what numerous post offices a dozen plus
that are all telling their supervisors
to bring in late ballots and then back
date them so we can count them like it's
it seems like it's not going to have an
impact you see what I'm saying
I think it's going to have if any impact
it's going to be extremely marginal and
to really get Traction in the courts
here you would have to do something
which has not yet been done which is at
least
give some indication
and granted you would need further
investigation to uncover this I grant
that but you need to give some
indication that there is a widespread
coordinated
effort at undermining the legitimacy
election
that's that's what I think would need
need to be established especially if you
have it across multiple States I mean
we're talking about Pennsylvania talking
about Georgia Arizona I don't know if
you want to throw Wisconsin in there in
Michigan but but it's not just one state
here where you can devote all your
resources to uncovering every individual
uh but but I
I disagree I don't think it needs to be
a widespread coordinated thing I think
it could be what's referred to as a
standalone complex you've got these
individuals who are zealous very
ideologically motivated and all it takes
is uh individuals acting in such a way
that it looks like there's some kind of
some type of concerted effort it could
just be one guy being like man I hate
Trump screw this and then crumpling up a
ballot but you get 100 people doing that
every so often because they hate Trump
then you've got widespread for priority
that's not coordinated yeah I don't
think it would necessarily have I should
have I should rephrase that I don't
think it has to be widespread and
coordinated in order to have some kind
of
potency in terms of affecting outcome
and you're right there probably are
people with a lot of zeal who don't like
Trump and maybe fudge some things I mean
that's plausible
but for it to be replicated across so
many states
I think it's going to be it's a it's
it's a it's a huge stretch to think that
anything is going to be uh over the way
I put it is like and in Georgia for
example where I just was I mean I spent
the election in Georgia with a week
leading up to it or so
and you know when Trump
I think was the day it was the day after
the election when he gave some remarks
first of all he misstated that the
secretary of state of Georgia was a
Democrat he's not so one reason why I
find a lot of these claims implausible
that I'm being inundated with on Twitter
which I'm sure you probably are as well
is that you know it would have to
Encompass a huge amount of Republicans
as well but that's that's what people I
think tend to miss about election
Administration it really is baking to
the cake that it has to be bipartisan a
lot of ways now maybe it's not always
abided by with 100 Perfection but in
Georgia for example you have the
Secretary of State the governor the
lieutenant governor both chambers of the
state legislature are held by
Republicans I was there in Atlanta in
the State Farm Arena where the Atlantic
Hawks used to play where they were
tabulating votes and there were
Republican observers everywhere the
Republican observers in the Fulton
County uh Warehouse where there was
other copulation taking place so I mean
and it was open to the public so this I
I think it really at least should be
emphasized to people who don't have
familiarity with this process that it's
not like secretive and closed off for
the most part could you find isolated
incident is in a country of 330 million
I'm sure you can but like I just freely
went in I didn't flash any media
credential anybody could go in and
observe I mean I watched Republicans and
Democratic Republican Democratic
observers jointly looking at ballots
that weren't properly processed so they
could adjudicate whether they were valid
yeah and you know so you know I'm not a
I'm far from an American exceptionalist
in most cases but there is something I
think at least laudable about the
transparency that elections tend to be
conducted within
um and uh
sorry about that I thought I thought I
put my phone on on airplane mode but
um and you know I don't think we're
going to be exporting our election
models around the world by force because
I mean
really it's over a week now we still
don't have calls in Arizona and Georgia
I mean it's ridiculous North Carolina I
saw was just called the police by
decision desk HQ I think but but but the
the point is that
um
yeah I sort of lost my train of thought
but you saw her I was going there thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification Bell and we
are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time